[Music]
Celine Dion she turns 50 today
happy birthday Queen we love her so much
sling currently on a two-month hiatus
from her Vegas residency to have and
recover from ear surgery and we know at
least for today she's able to take her
mind off of it she's black she's white
yeah yeah yeah the Sun is showing Robbie
you a source tells ET Celine had a big
celebration plan during her Vegas show
but since the show date was canceled
she's spending today with her kids and
loved ones instead of course we all
remember how the mom of three catapulted
into icon status with the Titanic ballad
in 1997
[Applause]
even her eldest son 17-year old Rene
Charles is in awe of his mom reflecting
on the song's 20th anniversary at last
year's Billboard Music Awards do you
understand how popular and what that
song means to this entire generation oh
it's crazy I'm just an iconic song it's
very special 20 years already I'm like
oh okay see we're gonna need a to hold
down on something I don't know she looks
to us like she's holding on just fine as
she celebrates this milestone birthday
cuz seriously who else could pull off an
amazing dress like that Celine Celine
are you there
Celine we wish her a speedy recovery
Queen and by the way keep in mind she's
scheduled to be back on stage in Vegas
May 22nd
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]